[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory today
we're going to once again be discussing
the third installment of the fantastic
beasts franchise fantastic beasts
secrets of dumbledore the film just came
out in north america a few days ago and
by this point it's come out in theaters
across most of the world so i thought
it'd be a good time to release a list of
my pros and cons limiting myself to just
five of each if you want a full scale
review and breakdown i've done that as
well i'll leave a link down in the
pinned comment i'll be alternating pros
with cons as to not overly hype up or
bog down the experience let's get into
it
pro number one actors characters and
casting
starting things off on a good note the
first thing that i'd like to point out
is that both the acting and casting in
the fantastic beast films is excellent
before this latest film jude lore
already smashed it as young dumbledore
as did eddie redmayne who plays newt's
commander however this latest film
includes several new main actors to the
fantastic beasts series including maz
mickelson and jessica williams maz
mickelson took over for johnny depp in
the role of grindelwald and man all i
can say is that he absolutely killed it
i thought johnny was good too but i'm
personally of the impression that maz
was made for this role his seamless
performance as grindelwald was a huge
pro for me and it honestly felt as if he
had actually been in the previous films
on a separate note i felt that the
inclusion of new witch ulalli hicks was
a great choice
hicks played by jessica williams is an
ilvermorny professor who ends up helping
the protagonists and there is a certain
charm surrounding her character i think
she was a wonderful addition
con number one no tina or barely any
tina anyway when the secrets of
dumbledore trailers were first coming
out and no one could find tina goldstein
in them it was a bit worrisome however
as time went on and as i thought about
it more i figured she had to be in the
film i said this to myself because a
queenie her sister is in the trailer
b she was a large part of the first two
films and c we know that she eventually
marries newt
so bearing all that in mind i must say
that i was quite surprised when tina was
so very absent from the story the
explanation tina was promoted this
doesn't make sense at all her sister is
in danger the wizarding world is in
danger and newt her love interest is in
danger why on earth wouldn't she be
there to help what could be more
important she shows up at the end but
i'd rather she didn't with that
explanation regardless of how you feel
about tina's character this was a big
con
pro number two soundtrack i'm going to
keep this one brief as it speaks for
itself the music
james newton howard did the soundtrack
for the secrets of dumbledore and he
absolutely smashed it capturing the
magic perfectly
a poor soundtrack can so profoundly
impact the feel of the film
with the film like harry potter which
depicts a magical world this becomes
even more important
no complaints at all from me here con
number two chillin bows to dumbledore
in this film we're introduced to a
creature called a chillin which holds
the special ability to recognize those
that are pure of heart
in order to acknowledge that an
individual is pure of heart the chilean
will bow to them and this is an
important part of the election that
takes place in the film at one point
when the real chilean surfaces it walks
around the election site trying to find
a worthy witch or wizard and finally it
stops at dumbledore who would then bows
to
this doesn't make sense to me because
it's highlighted in the film that barely
anyone is entirely pure of heart and
that for the chilling to bow to you
you've got to basically be a saint this
completely contradicts dumbledore's
character who we know to have quite a
dark history
dumbledore is mostly good these days but
he certainly knows saint particularly if
he at any time plotted to take over the
wizarding world i don't quite understand
this
pro 3 brings magic back to the franchise
i mention this in my full review but i
want to emphasize that this film felt
way more harry pottery
yes the fantastic beast films are
prequels and separate important
distinctions to be aware of but that
doesn't mean that filmmakers can't
bridge the gap between the two film
franchises
though still very different feeling than
harry potter itself i definitely felt
magic in this film that the previous two
installments were lacking
this was a huge one for me
con number three nagini some people
probably didn't even notice this but
nagini was completely stripped from this
film and there was absolutely no
explanation
in the previous film nagini became quite
close with credence and it also started
to look like she would become a more
prominent character
we know that later on once the harry
potter stories timeline sets in that
nagini becomes a prevalent character
voldemort's trusty serpentine companion
but when the crimes of grindelwald ended
nagini wasn't yet trapped as a snake the
result of her maledictus curse
so it's confusing that she's just been
removed with no in-universe explanation
pro number four expanding the dumbledore
family i mentioned this in my review as
well but i think it's extremely exciting
that one of the most enigmatic wizarding
families the dumbledores are having an
adjustment made to their family tree
time will tell what happens to credence
but this does open up a big can of worms
and it's quite exciting con number four
queenie's redemption
in the last film queenie goldstein
tina's sister has a large argument with
her now husband jacob over his
unwillingness to marry her this leads to
her disoperating to paris where she ends
up having a run-in with grindelwald's
acolytes
long story short queenie makes an
extremely misguided decision when she
chooses to join grindelwald in the hopes
of building a future where she can be
with jacob
queenie seemed good up to this point and
she can read minds so this decision of
hers didn't make much sense this brings
us to the secrets of dumbledore
queenie's role as one of grindelwald's
acolytes is essentially to read the mind
of credence who grindelwald hopes he
will be able to use as a weapon against
dumbledore
beyond that queenie's significance in
the film is low but what i found
annoying is just how quickly queenie was
redeemed it seems like one moment she
was evil and the next she was back with
jacob as if nothing had happened i don't
think that she necessarily deserved to
be redeemed quite so quickly and i wish
they focused on this more pro number
five the right direction
though the secrets of dumbledore film is
being criticized quite heavily i do feel
as though these films are really
beginning to head in the right direction
where the first film contributed very
little to the harry potter universe as a
whole we're progressively getting more
and more of a sense of what life in the
wizarding world was like before harry
potter and more importantly what the
foundations of things were like
we're getting deep into the law and i'm
here for it con number five use of karma
in this film dumbledore gives all of the
protagonists a different task the
ultimate goal of defeating confusing
grindelwald one of these protagonists is
yusuf karma whose task is basically to
infiltrate grindelwald's people yusuf's
role in the film seems very
insignificant and unimportant only
really helping out at one moment towards
the end when he helps lally and theseus
in defeating grindelwald's acolytes
honestly i think it was just a waste of
his character
and that's it for this video
do you agree with these what are your
pros and cons comment down below until
next time remember we must all face the
choice between what is right and what is
easy
you